et pour en parler on nous sommes en
direct ce soir avec françoise souvent si
les général de brigade et expert en
géopolitique
bonsoir françois alfonsi merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur ft france pour
essayer de faire simple sur cette
situation de de cessez-le-feu en dans le
haut karabakh il y à l'enclavé du
haut-karabakh et des zones autour
d'où les arméniens sont en train de
quitter justement cette zone pour
regagner l l'arménie et il y à la
situation dans le haut-karabagh où là il
ya encore des arméniens comment ces
arméniens vont-ils pouvoir être protégé
est ce que ça va être une des parties de
la mission russe sans aucun doute je
crois que dès qu'il ya une sortie de
crise avec une population civile
pourraient échanger qui a peur
d'ailleurs des représailles et bon
finalement de la populaire de l'armée
azérie il est tout à fait normal qu'une
force 10 d'apport ta position puisse se
mettre en contact en interposition entre
ces forces armées et là puis las aussi
donc c'est tout à fait normal ça se fait
partout pour justement assurer une
sortie de crise acceptable et quelles
vont être les autres missions de ces
soldats russes assurer des liaisons
entre l'arménie et cette enclave du haut
karabagh oui sans aucun doute puisqu'il
ya un sens de coordination qui est prévu
justement avec l'état-major russe je
dirais sur place bon ces deux belong to
déployé ce n'est pas rien ensuite on
sait que les troupes russes sont quand
même des troupes qui sont efficaces et
tout sera fait sans aucun doute pour
qu'il n'y ait aucune dérive locale et
que la transition entre je dirais le
nouveau régime azéri
[Musique]
se passe bien pour éviter que justement
il y ait des solutions violentes
localement donc c'est ce qui va se
passer certainement d'un point de vue
géopolitique en quoi les les azéri avait
à gagner à signer cet accord puisque ils
ont maintenant des troupes russes sur
leur sol je me demande si les azéris
attendait à voir des troupes ce russe en
interposition mais je pense que le
président poutine a su faire preuve je
dirais d'autorité au bout de six
semaines où je pense pas qu'il en ait
fait beaucoup du moins il n'a pas
exprimé une position très forte et a
laissé les combats se déroulent et je
dirais que c'est un petit peu le retour
sur investissement à terme ou oui les
troupes
l'azerbaïdjan doit accepter des troupes
russes c'est peut-être la seule
condition pour que le cessez-le-feu se
maintiennent et puis un autre côté je
pense aussi que c'est un moyen pour la
russie de préserver l'arménie qui sort
quand même bien amoindrie de cette
situation militaire et est-ce qu'on peut
pas dire ce soir qu'il y a néanmoins
même si le statu quo officiellement
n'existe plus mais cette enclave du haut
karabakh est toujours à majorité
arménienne même si elle est
officiellement j'ai réparé par les
azerbaïdjanais aujourd'hui alors c'est
en clair quand on regarde bien c'est
cent cinquante mille personnes 150 mille
arméniens dont depuis quinze jours ont
dit qu'elles quittent la zone
je ne crois pas comme ça c'est vu
ailleurs d'ailleurs que les arméniens
voudront rester sous l'autorité de
l'azerbaïdjan
donc je pense que nous allons assister à
des déplacements de population ah si
nous mêmes un exode et que là il faudra
bien que l'arménie prennent en compte
ces nouveaux exilés sur un territoire
quand même qui est pas très grand avec
des moyens limités et sans doute que la
russie n'hésitera pas à aider à la
réinstallation de cette population
arménienne qui est obligé de quitter une
zone dans lesquelles s'est installée si
l'arménie n'avait pas signé cet accord
de cessez-le-feu est ce qu'elle aurait
encore plus perdus aujourd'hui on sait
que le premier ministre est très
critiquée oui il ya la question de
politique intérieure quand un politicien
pire une guerre ça se paye vis à vis son
opinion publique surtout quand il ya des
élections
bon bah je pense que c'est un peu
dans tous les pays ce serait un peu
comme cela d'un autre côté l'arménie
aurait pu perdre beaucoup plus je pense
mais si l'azerbaïdjan a étalé était allé
plus loin que les enclaves
je pense que la russie aurait été
contrainte d'intervenir au nom de la
protection de l'arménie je vous rappelle
que l'arménie fait partie de la même
alliance militaire et de sécurité que la
russie est que ces titres-là la russie
se devrait et aurait dû le protéger
ce qui ne concerne pas le karabakh le
haut-karabakh c'était pas dans l'accord
n'était pas dans l'alliance maintenant
si laser réclusion est allé plus loin
oui je pense que la russie aurait été
largement duilhé et donc le cessez le
feu était obligatoire quelles
conséquences pour le paysage régional la
russie renforce sa façon son influence
régionale
qu'en est il de la turquie qui est assez
absent de cet accord de cessez-le-feu
je pense que tout a été fait pour que la
turquie ne soit pas présente
parce que la turquie a une tendance
aujourd'hui à avoir une certaine volonté
expansionniste
il est certain que l'aide qu'elle a
apportée à des arbitres jean a permis la
victoire de l'azerbaïdjan mais pas
uniquement un je vous rappelle que 65%
de l'équipement azéri est d'origine
russe et pâtures 15 malgré les drones
envoyés par les turcs malgré des
supplétifs islamistes envoyés donc
effectivement la turquie mises de côté
mais pourquoi parce que la turquie a une
volonté islamiste très bon c'est quand
on envoie des supplétifs islamistes
venant de syrie je comprends aussi que
la russie soit peut-être un peu inquiète
tu n'as pas envie du tout à mon avis
d'avoir ce genre de deux miliciens ses
frontières je pense qu'il doit y avoir
aussi des pressions sur la turquie pour
qu'elle reste mesuré dans ses peut-être
éventuelle revendication par exemple au
à la sortie politique de la crise ou un
film en elle et pas du tout présente
elle est allée deux côtés voilà merci
beaucoup françois chouet ancien d'avoir
répondu ce soir en direct à nos
questions sur leur défense